key reason is that everybody of course
has strengths and weaknesses you will
often notice especially the types of
things where they are better than you so
in areas where you have clear weaknesses
it is often especially clear to you when
the other people in your environment
perform better for instance some people
are extremely good at mental math and if
maybe you aren't that good at it and if
you see somebody in front of you doing
crazy things with mental math then of
course you will feel stupid of course
you will feel like these guys are so
much smarter than you are but maybe you
are much more empathetic than these
other guys maybe your strength will be
to handle client meetings but these
types of strengths of course aren't that
visible after only a couple of weeks and
for you it will be less obvious that
maybe this is something where you really
are better than other people